[Music]
have you ever been waiting in line at
the grocery store innocently perusing
the magazine rack when a song pops into
your head
not the whole song but a fragment of it
that plays and replays until you find
yourself unloading the vegetables in
time to the beat you've been struck by
an earworm and you're not alone over 90%
of people are plagued by ear worms at
least once a week and about a quarter of
people experience them several times a
day they tend to burrow in during tasks
that don't require much attention say
when waiting on water to boil or a
traffic light to change this phenomenon
is one of the mine's great mysteries
scientists don't know exactly why it's
so easy for Tunes to get stuck in our
heads from a psychological perspective
ear worms are an example of mental
imagery this imagery can be visual like
when you close your eyes and imagine a
red wagon or it can be auditory like
when you imagine the sound of a baby
scream or oil sizzling in a pan ear
worms are a special form of auditory
imagery because they're involuntary you
don't plug your ears and try to imagine
who let the dogs out or well and
probably don't it just intrudes on to
your mental soundscape and hangs around
like an unwanted houseguest ear worms
tend to be quite vivid and they're
normally made up of a tune rather than
say harmonies a remarkable feature of
ear worms is their tendency to get stuck
in a loop repeating again and again for
minutes or hours also remarkable is the
role of repetition in sparking new ones
songs tend to get stuck when we listen
to them recently and repeatedly if
repetition is such a trigger then
perhaps we can blame our ear worms on
modern technology the last hundred years
have seen an incredible proliferation of
devices that help you listen to this
thing again and again records cassettes
CDs or streamed audio files have these
technologies bred some kind of unique
contemporary experience and our ear
worms just a product of the late 20th
century the answer comes from an
unlikely source mark twain in 1876 just
one year before the photograph was
invented he wrote a short story
imagining the sinister takeover of an
entire town by a rhyming jingle this
reference and others show us that ear
worms seem to be a basic psychological
phenomenon
perhaps exacerbated by reporting
technology but not new to this century
so yes every great historical figure
from Shakespeare to Sacagawea may well
have wandered around with a song stuck
in their head besides music it's hard to
think of another case of intrusive
imagery that's so widespread why music
why don't water colors get stuck in our
heads or the taste of cheesy taquitos
one theory has to do with the way music
is represented in memory when we listen
to a song we know we're constantly
hearing forward in time anticipating the
next note it's hard for us to think
about one particular musical moment in
isolation if we want to think about the
pitch of the word you in happy birthday
we have to start back at happy and sing
through until we get to you in this way
a tune is sort of like a habit just like
once you start tying your shoe you're on
automatic until you tighten the bow once
a tune is suggested because for example
someone says my umbrella we have to play
through until it reaches a natural
stopping point ella ella ella but this
is largely speculation the basic fact
remains we don't know exactly why we're
susceptible to ear worms but
understanding them better could give us
important clues to the workings of the
human brain maybe the next time you're
plagued by a Taylor Swift tune that just
go away we'll use it as the starting
point for a scientific Odyssey that will
unlock important mysteries about basic
cognition and if not well we can just
shake it off
[Music]